la justicia Argentina emitió sentencia
para uno de los casos más polémicos en
toda su historia Cristina Fernández de
kirchner vicepresidenta y ex mandataria
de la nación fue condenada por un caso
de corrupción el cual habría tenido
lugar entre 2003 y 2015 condenar a
Cristina Elizabeth Fernández de kirchner
a la pena de seis años de prisión
inhabilitación especial perpetua para
ejercer cargos públicos accesorias
legales y las costas del proceso por
considerar la autora penalmente
responsable del delito de administración
fraudulenta en perjuicio de la
Administración pública el juicio inició
en mayo de 2019 y es conocido como caso
vialidad la fiscalía pedía 12 años de
prisión para la líder política luego de
acusarla de liderar una asociación
ilícita que gestionó el otorgamiento de
51 Obras Públicas al empresario Lázaro
báez cercano al matrimonio kirchner
sin embargo no se trata de una condena
firme dado que quien fuera dos veces
presidenta del país deberá esperar a que
se den a conocer los fundamentos de la
condena previstos para 2023
recién a partir de ese momento podrá
apelar
la política de 69 años cuenta con fueros
que la blindan de una eventual detención
hasta diciembre de 2023 cuando termine
su mandato como vicepresidenta la
política quien ha negado desde el primer
día las acusaciones y asegura ser
víctima de una persecución política
escuchó su sentencia de manera virtual
esta condena con Patriotas no es una
condena por las leyes de la Constitución
o por las leyes administrativas o por el
código penal esto es un estado paralelo
y mafia mafia judicial entre tanto miles
de argentinos salieron a las calles a
reaccionar frente a este caso que divide
aún más a una sociedad ya polarizada y
parece estar lejos de llegar a su fin